- [Instructor] What we're
going to do in this video
is review what we know about line plots,
but apply them in a situation
where some of our data involves fractions.
So they tell us the lengths
of some caterpillars
are shown below, and so we can see
that here in the line plot,
just to refresh our minds
how to read a line plot,
this tells us that we
have two caterpillars
that are four centimeters long.
These three show that we
have three caterpillars
that are seven centimeters long.
Each dot represents a caterpillar
whose length we are measuring.
It allows us to see how those
lengths are distributed.
For example, we have a lot of
caterpillars at this length.
What is that length?
Well we can see that is exactly
half way between four and five,
so that is four and one
half centimeters long.
We divide the section
between four and five
into two equal sections, and we're going
one of those two equal
sections towards five,
so this is four and a half centimeters.
I can ask you some questions.
How many total caterpillars were measured?
Pause this video and think about that.
Well each dot represents
a caterpillar measurement,
and we have one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven,
eight, nine, 10, 11,
12, 13, 14, 15, 16, 17.
So we have a total of 17 caterpillars.
Now another question
we could ask ourselves
is how many of the caterpillars
are five and one fourth centimeters long?
Pause the video and think about that.
Well five and one fourth is
going to be more than five,
and what we'd want to do to
get to five and one fourth
is divide the interval or the
length between five and six
into four equal sections,
they already did that,
one, two, three, four,
and then we want to go
one of those four equal sections.
So five and one fourth is right over here
and we can see that
there's one caterpillar
that is five and one
fourth centimeters long.
We can ask ourselves other questions.
How many caterpillars,
let me write it over here,
how many have length
more than six and one half centimeters?
Pause the video and try to answer that.
Where is six and a half centimeters?
Well, we can divide the
section between six and seven
into two equal sections, and if you go
one of those two equal sections,
that is six and a half,
so that is six and a
half right over there.
How many have a length
more than or greater than
six and a half centimeters?
Well we can see it right over here.
One, two, three, four, five, six.
Six of them do.
And we can even try to
answer questions like
how many more have a length
of nine and a half centimeters
than five and one fourth centimeters?
Try to answer that question.
Well nine and a half centimeters,
that's half way between nine
and 10, right over there.
We can see two of them have a length of
nine and a half centimeters.
And we already know that one of them
has a length of five and one fourth,
so how many more have nine
and a half centimeters
versus five and one fourth?
Well that would be two
minus one, or one more.
We have one more caterpillar with a length
of nine and a half centimeters
than we do with five and one fourth.
I'll leave you there.
We have plenty of examples on Khan Academy
for you to practice this.